Willkommen an der Militärakademie in Wiener
Neustadt. Mein Name ist Oberst Markus Reissner
ich bin der Leiter der Entwicklungsabteilung
und ich werde Ihnen heute die Gliederung einer
Russischen Bataillonskampfgruppe erklären. Jenes
Element das von den Russischen Streitkräften in
der Ukraine zur zeit sich im Einsatz befindet.
Dazu schauen wir uns jetzt im Detail die
Gliederung an die Gliederung Russischen Bataillons
Kampf Gruppe kann man grob in folgende Elemente
unterteilen in die Kampfteile hier befinden
sich die motorisierten und mechanisierte
Infanteriekräfte sowie eine Kampfpanzer Kompanie
zusätzlich in einem sehr hohem Maße verfügbar sind
die Teile der Kampfunterstützung dies umfasst
mitgeführte Fliegerabwehr, raketen artillerie
mittlerer reichweite raketen artillerie kurzer
reichweite und rohr artillerie sowie zusätzliche
weitere anteile zum beispiel der pionier kräfte
zusätzlich haben elemente der führung und elemente
der drohnen aufklärung und elektronischen
kampfführung sowie einen versorgungs anteil
zur versorgung dieser kräfte mit betriebsmittel
waffen munition verpflegung sehen wir uns nun
als beispiel der kampf elemente eine kampfpanzer
komponieren das hauptsystem ist der b72 dieser
die 72 existiert in unterschiedlichen
ausführungen eine kompanie umfasst zehn
fahrzeuge gehen wir nun zurück und sehen uns
die kampf unterstützungs teile noch einmal an
die kampf unterstützungs anteile
haben wie gesagt wo artillerie
aber auch raketenwerfer sowie flieger ab
aber spezielles element mit verheerender
wirkung den sogenannten ts 1 buratino
genannt das russische wort für pinocchio
dieser theorie science ist dafür
vorgesehen wenn die kampf teile
auf widerstand treffen halten diese und
der theorie science verschießt auf kurze
entfernung von drei bis vier kilometer ein
verheerendes flächen wirksames feuer durch
der moralische raketen damit führt
das räumte im widerstand ist gegen
der zur seite und die kampfpanzer und info bz
mechanisierten teilen können weiter angreifen
als weiteres beispiel bataillons
kampfgruppe sehen wir uns die führung an
diese führung verfügt nicht nur über
bodengestützte aufklärungsmittel sondern
auch über mitgeführte thronen systeme wie hier
in diesem beispiel das duale system das im
wesentlichen die aufklärung für die kampf
unterstützungs teile zur verfügung stellt
somit haben die gruppe gliederung der ptg
dargestellt ich danke fürs zuhören und alles gute